you want to tell us uh first let's let's
let's start here in america you said
that
what's happening here with critical race
theory and i think it's it's important
to mention it's it's well beyond
critical race theory but this these
these changes we're seeing from the left
this is a culture revolution in in
america
well as somebody who survived mouse
culture revolution
it's very terrifying to see lots of
similarities
the similarities
that people who don't know about mouse
cultural revolution he used karl marx
theory
communist manifesto author
to separate people into
primarily two
big groups will heard those names
oppressor versus oppressed
and who are under oppressors group in
mouth china
rich farmers
landlord
rightist bad influencers
and
country revolutionaries
suspect many
bad influencers yeah who are those
people and rightists yes that's like
basically anybody they could just be
like you're a bad influencer anybody who
is not in eye
with a
mouse party which is
one party run in china today
ccp china's communist party
and anybody who disagrees with the party
policies
or trying to offer some suggestions to
say we can improve china better
maybe by doing better
economically
you all can be classified as the
so-called black classes five classes
they're under oppressed
i was one of supposed to be oppressed
called
workers
peasants
communist party members officials
people's liberation armies
because comedies when's all about
polo terrence rule
workers unite right have you heard that
before marxist terms
oh you could call that equity equity
today do people even know that's a
company's term equity equal outcomes
by forcefully doing
wealth redistribution
that's what the mon did he promised
we're going to have
you know land
taking from the rich give to the
peasants we're going to take over all
the private properties like factories
industries
so we can
give to the people equally
people always buy into that kind of
promise that never came you know never
can and how many people did he kill to
to enact that vision
under mao 20 to 40 million people
storming to death
during the great leap forward campaign
he did from 1958 to 1961
then during his 10 years cultural
revolution from 1966 to 1976
20 million people died add those lumber
together our kids have no idea when i
tell them do you know more people died
under
mouse communist china than hitler
no did not know that
too bad we don't teach emphasize the
horrors of
communism especially on their mouth
i went to venezuela once and i went to a
protest
the people who were protesting were
described as wealthier more upper middle
class more successful business owners
and i noticed something interesting that
in a lot of places you you mentioned
that people always buy this this lie
that we're going to take from the rich
and give to the poor well it's simple
they're they're they're saying we're
going to give you stuff and so for these
people who are living you know it
doesn't matter what class you are being
told you're going to get free stuff
people are like i'll take stuff so what
ends up happening is i see this with you
know occupy wall street i see with other
protests in other countries
there
in many ways you'll see the poor people
will protest when conditions are bad for
the poor and then when you get this
inversion like in venezuela where they
take away the property from the middle
class it was actually middle class and
upper class people protesting because
they couldn't they couldn't survive they
couldn't succeed and they're the ones
producing in the country so it was
interesting it seems like
in it you know the the rightists or
whatever are they they're of course
going to oppose
this effort to strip away the wealth and
the resources they build and give it to
other people
i don't see how it's noble or honorable
to take from somebody who has made a
bunch of things
by force within reason mind you
to just give it away to everybody else
arbitrarily especially when there's no
agreement there's no social contract and
that's one of the biggest problems we
have today which is why so many
libertarians say taxation is theft
um i think there is a line but i i do
find it to be particularly interesting
long story short it doesn't matter if
it's communist china it doesn't matter
if it's cuba venezuela or even the
united states now in the united states
they're saying the oppressors and the
oppressed and they're using race to get
what they want so now you have this idea
i guess they're claiming
who are they claiming are the oppressors
now
typically whites is heteronormative men
right you have your own new
oppressors groups in oppressed groups
but say to me though it's not even about
race or skin color
it's really
about the cultural revolution like a
male
did right
because malware used a critical class
series
to destroy
thousands of years of chinese
civilization culture
and religion arts one-third of cultural
relativity
were destroyed yeah
taiwan hong kong people preserve more of
traditional chinese culture
even beautiful you know like chinese
dresses
were banned to wear during mall time i
cannot lay my hair down like this it's
old style i cannot wear beautiful sexy
woman's dresses because
that was capitalist so everything has to
be in line conform to collective society
well here's what i think happened uh in
in china it was mostly mostly ethnically
chinese so critical
critical class theory is what you'd have
to use right in order to create your
press and oppressor uh the critical race
theorists notably kimberly crenshaw
wrote
that uh in her book critical race theory
that they called it critical race
theories that people would understand
that it came from critical theory from
marxist ideology and the idea conveyed
in the book is that
marx didn't understand the racial
dynamics that happened in the united
states about who is the oppressor and
who is the oppressed and he seems to
think you know his ideas of class only
work in these old world you know
ethnically homogeneous places so they
needed to create a new framework that
was race-based for the us and this was
back i think was like the late 70s early
80s and now it's come straight to the
forefront you know some 30 40 years
later now it's in our schools they're
lying saying it's not in our schools but
what's it what what they've done is
they keep changing the goal they keep
moving the goal posts oh it's not it's
not uh um you know critical race theory
it's something else oh it's not feminism
it's something else oh we're just
teaching people not to be bigots and
then every step of the way they're
they're indoctrinating into this these
this marxist ideology so we get caught
up in things like critical race theory i
hear from all the time from parents
saying critical race there in our
schools and i said have you talked about
critical theory in general or critical
gender theory and they don't so
that's one of the things that keeps
people kind of running in circles is the
con constant semantic debate but it
isn't our it is in our schools now it's
critical race applied principle children
are being taught all of these ideas in
their in their curriculums not just as a
whole so the teachers aren't saying open
up your critical race theory books the
teachers are saying open up your science
book and learn about the critical theory
of the frog or something
they're injecting the ideology it's
called praxis they're putting it into
the literature
now these kids are gonna grow up and
they're gonna they're gonna believe this
stuff they're gonna be a part of that so
we may be
ten years away from our ideal
ideological idealistic college kids we
already have them obviously but imagine
now all these grade school kids who are
being indoctrinated imagine when they're
in school and then there's some
charismatic cultural marxist
leader who comes around he's a little
older and he rallies all of these kids
now who are in their 20s
that could come here and we will face a
cultural revolution in what a decade
well that's one of the similarities i
see
is to
indoctrinate
indoctrinate our youth make them
religiously following so-called social
justice movement right and follow all
this critical risk whatever new name
they might give it so basically it is
about the
um
equity they just use race car use gender
issues and
you have to use identity politics to
separate your citizens it's a typical
maoist marxist way to do
divide and conquer how do you divide
people mounted by classes right five red
five black and what are the marxists
doing in our country by race if you
trace back those critical race theory so
people cannot sell communism very
old-fashioned way by doing oh who is
poor who is rich but they can sell to
the country and people sensitive
compassionate buying the race game race
car and look you know all those people
who have different sexes different
genders different races skin color they
are oppressed but they don't know
oppressor versus oppressed that's
already typical marxist you know theory
mao is the theory then further divided
people into subgroups you have to get
people to fight each other hate each
other mao said revolution is not dinner
party
it's not embroidery revolution is about
crush your enemies with a hammer that's
what communist party symbol is right
use violence scare people
were you scared nastier when you say
what's going on in our streets
mao also used young people to top down
their statues destroy the cultural
relics
and alluding door-to-door by red cars
drum kitting go to searching the doors
get rid of all the people have to burn
bugs
hide their old dresses and hide all the
chinese arts or give them away bury them
so they don't go to concentrational
camps people don't get this
don't give this when the statues were
being torn down
these are the stories we we read about
in these books these were the the movies
we watched where you see the image of
the people throwing the ropes and
toppling the statues we we knew that
this was a component of what was going
on and then we watched it happen for a
year and so many people in this country
didn't care and i saw these
conversations people would say well you
know christopher columbus was a racist
or whatever and i'm like the point is
whether you agree or disagree
violent groups tearing down statues
without public conversations without any
any democratic values these are
authoritarians who are imposing their
will on everyone else
and no one asked for this if you allow
these people to keep doing whatever they
want and that's what's happened
eventually they just take absolute
authority and then what they will do is
substantially worse than what they're
doing now we had a man uh on the show
he was uh uh an act he was a freedom
fighter in
after the revolution in cuba he said if
these people get real power they'll
start killing people
well
they did i mean how many people died
the most sad part is they get the
children turn on
on their parents grandparents and the
neighbors
friends
i learned my lesson i can't trust my
friends my friend reported to teacher
about
i was bragging about my good grades in
schools as seven years old oh she was
full of herself she was overly confident
bragging about her grace should be first
one to join mouse young pioneer group
read that red scarf
i was pushed back for a year not to join
mouse young pioneer to wear that red
scarf i was red child i was very
competitive i wanted to do it i want to
be first group to wear red scarf
i got a spy a friend reported to
teachers i got to go into teacher
principal office who say
sorry
you're full of yourself
in our collective society your
individual expression confidence are not
allowed
you better to act like one of the other
students keep your head down conform
i learned my lesson the same and i never
forget that lesson i never forget to
remind myself don't trust anybody
in this society and i become red guard
later and i become even communist youth
member when i was in college and after
graduate from law school i wanted to
teach in shanghai i had to join
communist party in order to teach a
university to teach law otherwise were
your loyalty you know so i did all that
but i also learned in my back burner
oh i better not trust anybody i need to
be strategic what i say
is that sad i feel like that way today
about america i have to be careful about
what i said why am i getting cancelled
it's it's it's it's history is repeating
itself
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time